اعلن حكيم ومقاطعتي بالقرود الروسيه
تعرض منطقتي غرايفورون وجلوتوفو
الحدوديتين في المقاطعه صباح اليوم لقصف
اوكراني وقال غلاتكوف ان القصف الاوكرانيه
الحق اضرارا بعدد من المباني السكنيه في
المنطقتين دون وقوع ضحايا او اصابات واضاف
حاكم المقاطعه ان خطوط امدادات الغاز
والطاقه الكهربائيه تعرضت لاضرار نتيجه
القصف في منطقه جرايفورون
افاد عمده المواليه لروسيا بمقتل شخص في
القصف الاوكراني الذي استهدف مركز البحوث
العلميه كما افاد موقع ريدوفكا العسكري
الروسي بسقوط مسيره على احد المباني
بمدينه كرسنودار جنوبيه روسيا ونشر الموقع
صورا لمسيره تحلق فوق المدينه وتسبب
سقوطها في تضرر اجزاء من واجهته احد
المباني في المدينه
سياسيا قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسيه
فان الصراع الاوكرانيه الروسي الصراع
الاوكرانيه عفوا سيطول لفتره قد تصل الى
عقود واضاف فانهما دامت السلطه الاوكرانيه
الحاليه موجوده فستكون هناك ثلاث سنوات
هدنه وسنه صراع وسيتكرر ذلك على حديث
تعبيره واكد انه لانهاء النزاع يجب القضاء
على ما وصفه بالنظام النزي في كييف وحذر
من انه اذا زود الغرب اوكرانيا باسلحه
نوويه فحينها سوف تحتاج روسيا الى توجيه
ضربه استباقيه كما راى نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ان اوروبا اصيبت بالجنون
وتستمر في تسخين وتاجيج الموقف بقراراتها
الى رانيا
وتنضم الينا من بالقرود في المقابل الجانب
الروسي يتحدث عن قصف اوكرانيا لمناطق
حدوديه ما الذي عرف حتى الان عن هذا
الهجوم
نعم سهام بالفعل حاكم المقاطعه اشار الى
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قاصفت صباح اليوم
منطقتين منطقتين حدوديتين في مقاطعه
هذا القصف لم يصب يعني لم يلحق اضرار
ماديه في صفوف المدنيين لم يعني لم تكن
هناك اي اصابات او ضحيه ولكن بالفعل هناك
اضرار ماديه الحقت بمباني سكنيه بفضلا عن
ذلك في منطقه جريفارون يعني اصاب هذا
القصف خطوط انابيب الغاز وايضا نطاق
الكهربائيه وحاليا تعمل الهيئات المعنيه
على احتواء اثار هذا الحادث هذا كله
تزامنه ايضا مع اعلان السلطات هنا في وقت
سابق عن قيام احدى المسيرات بالقاء عبوه
ناسفه على احد المباني الاداريه في
المقاطعه الى جانب ذلك انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه قامت ايضا امس باسقاط مسيره ثانيه
اخرى اذا
القذف الاوكراني استهداف المناطق الحدوديه
في مقاطعه مستمر وياتي هذا كله سهام بعد
ميول مرور ايام معدوده على تسلل مجموعات
تصفها روسيا بالاستطلاعيه التقريبيه الى
المقاطعه وهو ما اعتبره العديد هنا من
المراقبين والمحللين العسكريين انها
محاوله من قبل كيف لصرف النظر عن الخساره
الاكبر التي تكبدتها القوات الاوكرانيه
وهي خساره مدينه
بالنسبه للسلطات هنا حاليا الاهم هو سهام
توفير امن هذه المناطق الحدوديه القرى
والمدن لسمه تلك المتاخمه للحدود والتي
تبعد على يعني مقربه كبيره جدا من هذه
الحدود ولذلك تم الاعلان عن تشكيل وحدات
من الدفاع الاقليمي تتالف هذه الوحدات من
نحو 3000 شخص حاليا يتم دراسه مساله تزويد
هذه الوحدات بالاسلحه
هذه الوحدات مؤلفه من السكان المحليين
الذين يقطنون
المقاطعه بهدف المساعده في توفير امن هذه
المناطق الحدوديه لاسيمه تلك القريبه جدا
من اوكرانيا شكرا لك يا رانيا الجزيره كنت
معنا من بيل